[Musique]
info ou intox et avec vous je lis chute
aux beaux jours bonjour à faire bonjour
à tous et à l'occasion des élections
législatives un c'est dans moins de deux
mois on voit poindre ici en france des
fausses infos et oui elle a le premier
tour ce sera le 12 juin prochain la
france a désigné ses cinq sens 77
députés qui vont siéger à l'assemblée
nationale en fin en principe par ils
sont élus pour ça mais certains seraient
atteints d'absentéisme aiguë selon
certains internautes et pour appuyer
leur propos il diffuse cette vidéo on y
voit un homme avec de nombreuses cartes
qu'ils insèrent dans vous avez ces
machines à voter dans plusieurs machines
à voter une manière nous dit-on de
dissimuler l'absence de ses collègues en
votant à leur place avec leurs badges
alors cette vidéo est très partagée
depuis la semaine dernière par des
opposants à émeutes emmanuel macron a
notamment selon eux elle montre des
députés la république en marche en train
de magouiller 1 pour cacher leur absence
mais cette vidéo et l authentique alors
pour le savoir il faut comme d'habitude
la regarder dans le détail d'abord les
cartes qui apparaissent à l'écran les
cartes que l'homme insère dans les
machines ne sont pas des cartes de
députés français mais celles de députés
ukrainiens regard me revient voilà
finalement 1 l'ukraine nous rattrape
toujours regarder à gauche les couleurs
des cartes qui donc sont extraites de la
vidéo ce sont exactement les mêmes que à
droite c'est une photo qui a été prise
par un photographe officiel dans
l'hémicycle de la radar donc le
parlement ukrainien et on voit bien là
ce sont exactement les mêmes ensuite
d'autres éléments ne correspond pas du
tout au palais bourbon c'est là où je
vous le rappelle siège l'assemblée
nationale française par exemple le sol
n'est pas rouge cette moquette rouge
comme à paris mais il est gris comme
dans la rade à une craignent n et si on
fait une recherche inversée eh bien on
se rend compte en fait que cette vidéo
filmée donc en ukraine a déjà utilisé de
manière trompeuse par le passé pour
dénoncer l'absentéisme des députés alors
un coup c'est en france un coup c'est au
brésil envoyé ça fait un peu le tour du
monde et cette vidéo est bien elle
ressort et en commun qu'ils utilisaient
hors de son contexte elle ressort encore
une nouvelle fois à l'occasion bien sûr
des législatives donc c'est acté un
cette vidéo elle n'a pas été tournée en
france et donc utilisée de manière
détournée ou fallacieuses est ce que ça
veut dire pour autant julie il n'y a pas
d' absentéisme du côté des députés de la
majorité la république en marche et bien
non raphaël parce que ce même si la
vidéo est fausse l'information selon
laquelle certains députés la république
en marche leur tendance à assécher les
réunions à l'assemblée eh bien ça bien
été révélé un par des médias sérieux par
le passé regarder cet article du
parisien en date du 16 janvier 2020 il
est titré le mystère des députés
fantômes alors là on voit la même
expression qui revient ces députés
fantômes à l'assemblée nationale et en
effet il est question de député lrm qui
boudent les réunions au palais bourbon
on quitte le palais bourbon direction a
présenté huit heures qui vient d'être
acheté par elon musk vous en a parlé un
sur france24 assez longuement l'homme le
plus riche du monde s'est payé twitter
elon musk qui prône une liberté
d'expression totale sur les réseaux
sociaux sur le réseau social ce qui
pourrait signer le retour de donald
trump suspendu par twitter deux jours
après l'assaut du capitole c'était le 9
janvier 2021 donc le compte de l'ex
président a été suspendu mais ils
seraient déjà revenus sur twitter à la
faveur donc du rachat de donald trump
c'est en tout cas ce que disent de
nombreux internautes qui partagent des
messages comme celui ci sauf que si on
regarde en détail regardez on voit que
le compte ne s'appelle pas will donald
trump comme celui de l'ex président mr
des états unis mais will donald trump
vient alors c'est vraiment ça se fait à
une lettre de différence mais bon c'est
pas le bon compte et des faux comptes de
ce genre en fait il y en a beaucoup à
chaque fois le procédé est le même on
change juste une ou deux lettres du nom
et voilà ça donne de risle dolalrs tron
coudry donald ross donc fait attention à
ses comptes twitter qui sont des faux
donc donald trump a dit qu'il ne
comptait pas revenir pour sur le réseau
social en tout cas pour l'instant
al'inverse bill gates lui n'a pas été
banni de twitter comme le disent
pourtant les messages vire ou sur
internet et oui aussitôt racheté par
elon musk twitter se serait débarrassé
de bill gates c'est ce qu'affirment des
messages comme celui ci avec cette image
présentée comme une capture d'écran
sauf que c'est complètement faux selon
les porte-paroles de bill gates qui
confirme que le fondateur de microsoft
n'a jamais été bannis twitter hélas là
la vérification est enfantine c'est
vraiment facile il suffit d'aller voir
sur le compte de bill gates on s'étonne
que certains ne le fasse pas c'est un
basique et pourtant il faut le faire on
voit que le compte est toujours actif il
faut dire que hélas de match lui même
hein s'amuse avec la vérité pour faire
des blagues et oui alors certains le
soupçonnent de vouloir acheter d'autres
marques puisqu'il a des grandes
ambitions de elon musk on le sait et
puis alors ils publient des messages de
ce type je vais acheter coca cola pour
remettre de la cocaïne dedans et ça
c'est bien lui qui l'a écrit alors c'est
de l'humour à la sauce donald me elon
musk ont apprécié où on n'apprécie pas
et dans le même genre le patron de tesla
se dit capable de racheter mcdonald's
pour réparer toutes les machines à glace
il montre au moins lui il milite pour la
liberté d'expression à commencer par la
sienne pour l'instant c'est le cas merci
ça dure merci julie choteau pour ce
décryptage des bonnes cage comme ont dit
un oui banking info intox avec julie
chouteau rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans quatre minutes pour un nouveau
journal sur france 24